des flacons hardy ou la non vous pensez
à quoi là à rien a tant mieux ouais ça
m'arrive souvent c'est bien pour ça que
c'est une grande comédienne nous arriver
complètement à faire le vide et vous
remplir des personnages non mais sérieux
samedi si la nation quand vous regardez
le matin dans les glaces où vous dites
quoi rien vous auriez aimé ressembler
quand vous étiez petit à personne c'est
vrai c'est vrai ah oui vraiment oui vous
avez pleuré quand pour la dernière fois
mais là j'étais en larmes dans ma loge
mais bon mandarine et vous changeriez
quoi en vous si vous aviez une baguette
magique rien qu'est ce que vous pourriez
dire de plus négatif sur vous rien
si votre vie était à refaire qu'est-ce
que vous changeriez rien mais vous
devriez appelez votre interne ou l'art
dit rien alors
rien vraiment vraiment sérieux on va et
sérieux vraiment sérieux qui avez vous
le plus envie d'épater personnes non
mais je vous dis non c'est vrai vos
enfants votre mari non et cette envie
qui le dit ce moment tu es génial ou ma
chérie tu extraordinaire non non ils ne
disent pas souvent ah ouais que feriez
vous si vous restez 24 heures à vivre à
part rien qu'est ce que je ferais rien
vous êtes déjà pensé au suicide
non non non non vous pouvez vous me
demandez ça parce que c'est écrit parce
que c'est la review willard où il est
comme ça pour tout le monde
de quelle question aimeriez vous avoir
la réponse celle que vous venez de me
poser
ah non
qu'est ce que la vie nous a appris rien
j'espère à rien encore comment
auriez-vous mourir mais j'aimerais mieux
pas ouais vous avez menti pendant cette
interview là tout le temps